what of course now we have found out
because every time the government tries
to do something it makes everything
worse the restrict Act is deeply deeply
dangerous it is not just about keeping
Tick Tock off your phone it actually is
about controlling you basically at every
possible level uh here is my friend
David Sachs on the all-in podcast
explaining the full effect of this in
essence legalized tyranny that they're
going through with the restrict Act
I think this is the biggest bait and
switch that Washington the central
government has ever tried to pull on us
everybody thinks that they're just
trying to ban Tick Tock from operating
the US and if that's all they did then I
think the bill would be supported by
most Americans but that's not what
they're doing they're not restricting
Tick-Tock they're restricting us that's
not the goal here yeah what a bait
switch it's a huge bait and switch and
so just so you know what the ACT
provides is that a U.S citizen using a
VPN to access Tick Tock could
theoretically be subjected to a maximum
penalty of one million in fines or 20
years in prison or both now
you know they'll say you know Mark
Warner the sponsored legislation will
swear up and down down that's not the
intent but the problem is the language
of the bill is so vague that some clever
prosecutor may want to pursue this
Theory one day and that needs to be
stopped also there's another problem
with the bill which is you think this is
just about Tick Tock it's not what they
do is it says here I guess they don't
want to mention Tick Tock by name so
they're trying to create a category of
threatening application but because it
is a category it's very very broad so
the bill states that it covers any
transaction transaction not just an app
in which an entity described instead of
paragraph B has any interest and then
entities described in some paragraph B
are quote a foreign adversary an entity
subject to the jurisdiction of
organizing the laws of a foreign
adversary an entity owned director
controlled by either of these and then
it gives the Executive Branch the power
to name a foreign adverse Siri any
foreign government regime that one of
the cabinet secretaries defines without
any vote of Congress we have this sort
of roughly right idea that we should get
Tick-Tock off Americans phones because
it's Chinese spyware and certainly off
young people's phones there's a whole
other reason for that because of what
they're pushing with all the trans
nonsense and everything else where they
don't push that on Tick Tock in China in
China they have these kids doing these
incredible mathematical equations and
all of this science and everything else
that's what they push to their own
people but to us it's all about you know
the gender craziness and everything else
that's one thing what David's really
referring to there is that within the
language it basically is saying any
communication that you have any Commerce
that you do with anyone once someone in
the government is like well we don't
like that company because maybe they
weren't doing enough for diversity
equity and inclusion we're going to
label them an enemy they will be able to
come for you you understand that they
will be able to look at your phone see
who you're texting who you're sending
money to what websites you're going to
and again and this is where a certain
set of not very bright people always say
well if I'm not doing anything wrong if
I'm not doing anything legal well then I
have nothing to worry about
first off they will find something you
know what I mean they will make it up
and what is socially Norm normed today
will be dangerous tomorrow that's how
the whole thing works
[Music]
foreign